in this weird way what we're not we're
not seeing things real time in the world
what we were able to see is that we live
in the past and and so I don't mean like
this or like this but but what I mean is
when you think when you think the moment
now occurs it's already happened a long
time ago it's already it's already past
by the time you think that you see it
for all you know my talk might be over
by now okay it's not it's not that far
but but what it means is that signals in
the brain take a large amount of time to
actually get processed and this is
because of the speed at which signals
come into the brain and it's actually an
extremely slow speed signals come into
the brain and they have to get processed
and pushed around and so on and then
finally you have this conscious
experience but it's always behind
reality and so what this means is that
your perception of the world is like one
of these live television shows like
Center nightlife which is not actually
live they air this with a delay in case
somebody cusses or falls down there's a
wardrobe mishap that kind of thing and
so what you're seeing is not actually
live and this is the same with our
perceptual lives